[BEEPS]
[GAME SOUND EFFECTS]
LILIANA YU: In
this episode, we'll
go over the fifth lab in the
GCP Essentials Quest, Hello Node
Kubernetes.
You can take this
lab on Qwiklabs
without needing to
take the previous ones.
But after completing all
the labs in this quest,
you will get this
fancy badge right here,
not to mention bragging rights.
So let's get right to it.
Kubernetes is an
open source system
for automating deployment,
scaling, and management
of containerized applications.
It can run on many
different environments,
from laptops to
high-availability, multi-node
clusters, from public clouds
to on-premise deployments,
from virtual machines
to bare metal.
It groups containers that
make up an application
into logical units for easy
management and discovery.
Kubernetes builds upon
15 years of experience
of running production
workloads at Google, combined
with best of breed ideas and
practices from the community.
The goal of this hands-on
lab is for you to turn code
that you have developed into a
replicated application running
on Kubernetes, which is
running on Kubernetes Engine.
For this lab, the code will be a
simple Hello World node.js app.
Here's a diagram of the various
parts in play in this lab
to help you understand how
the pieces fit together
with one another.
Use this as a reference as
you progress through the lab.
It should all make sense by
the time you get to the end.
This lab will take about
an hour to complete,
and you'll create a node.js
server, a Docker file that
describes the image you want
to build, a container cluster,
then a Kubernetes pod, and
then scale up your services
in case you suddenly need more
capacity for your application.
The lab only scratches the
surface of this technology.
And we encourage you
to explore further
with your own pods, replication
controllers, and services.
If you've been
following these videos
and completing these
Qwiklabs in order,
you're almost, almost
done with this quest.
Only two more labs to
go, and the next one
is Stackdriver Qwik Start.
[MUSIC PLAYING]